sort of a research topic both in the
database in the outdoor community and
then the plan is at two o'clock we're
going to drive the small group
today
without further Ado uh the mood is going
to sort of give the introduction
relationship
uh good morning everyone so the plan for
us today to discuss uh relational
algorithms which is on the boundary
between relational
databases and algorithms and some
machine learning depending on what kind
of algorithms we're talking about So the
plan is for me this morning to start by
giving you relation algorithms from the
perspective of the relational database
community and later Kirk is going to
present the algorithms Community
perspective
yeah Special thanks to Daniel for for
providing many helpful suggestions for
material for the slides and to Wolfgang
for volunteering to proofread the slides
please feel free to interrupt at any
time this will work work better if it is
a group discussion
foreign
so here is the outline we are going to
start by taking a look uh at a brief
definition of what we actually mean by
relational algorithms and then we will
take a detour to review some technical
tools that we need to develop uh some
class of relational algorithms in
particular the technical tools that we
are going to need are basically some
product queries
and then using those tools we will see
the one and only example that I'm going
to present today of a relational
algorithm which is relational linear
regression afterwards we will see how
far we can generalize this example and
we will end with some open-ended open
problems
so what exactly do we mean by relational
algorithms it's a little bit under
defined term but here's the high level
picture
the input to a relational algorithm is
basically relational data and the
algorithm is typically meant to utilize
the relational structure in order to
achieve either a better performance in
terms of space and time or better
results in terms of like accuracy if
this is let's say a machine learning
task depending on the problem at hand or
both and in some cases the output also
of the algorithm can be represented
relationally as relational data
so here is the
one example suppose that we are given
this database uh join a query and for
those of you in the audience who are not
from the database Community let me
review quickly what do we mean and by
actually join the query so over here we
have a query with four variables X1 X2
X3 Y and three binary tables
uh every table basically lists potential
assignments for its variables so this is
the table r s t and the output of the
joining query is basically a table with
four columns listing all possible
assignments of the variables that
satisfy this conjunction
so this is basically what we mean by
Azure in a query
and in a relational setup the setup that
is interesting to us for relational
algorithms the input is typically the
query
along with the input tables
our targeted output is not exactly to
compute the join itself instead it we
are asked to compute something that
depends on the join
this is basically the general idea we
want to compute something that depends
uh on the join without Computing the
join explicitly or at least trying not
to
and what exactly is something that we
want to compute could be there's
something that we we are asked to
compute it could be something that is
low level for example we could be asked
to compute some aggregation over uh the
table queue for example we could be
asked to compute the summation of Y
squared over all rows in the table Q
now another relational algorithm would
basically compute Q in full
and then go over the last column Y and
sum away y squared but this would take
uh time in the worst case the size the
multiplication of the sizes of R and T
because the Q itself
is basically a subset of the Cartesian
product of R and T
now instead a relational algorithm can
basically do this in a smarter way where
we can basically push the sum inside the
the join the query in particular here
for every fixed X3 we can start by
summing away y squared for this X3 and
the result would be just a function from
X3 to a number which is basically this
acceleration over here which we can do
in linear time in the size of t
uh after we do that now for every fixed
X2 we can go over x3s and some away in
this function that we just computed
and now this new function can also be
computed in time linear in the size of s
assuming we already computed the first
function and finally we go over uh X1 x2
in r
and compute the summation of the
previous function and everything will
take time linear in the input size
module or log Factor
so this is basically the simplest
example
of a relational aggregation algorithm
where we want to aggregate relationally
by pushing the aggregate inside the
query
a more advanced example
but this is not relational in the sense
that the aggregation is completely
oblivious to the join Equity we had to
we computed the full joint query before
we did the the aggregation so the
aggregation algorithm itself is not
really aware of the relational structure
of a queue it's just taking the queue as
a black box
I've got some databases actually run
that exact query right if you look at
the optimize it sometimes
so you mean non-relationally
yeah it can happen
again with a simple like sorting and all
that they usually just complete the
whole joint first and then apply
whatever operator afterwards
even good commercials
yeah
I was about to say thanks
so this is uh so sort of the simplest
relational
algorithm task
alternatively there are some higher
level computations that we might ask to
perform relationally so for example
we could be asked to train some machine
learning model on Queue using the table
queue as some training data so for
example we could be asked to train on a
queue so that we can predict why based
on X1 X2 xf3
and similarly an unrelational algorithm
would actually start by explicitly
materializing a queue as a giant Matrix
and then run machine learning a machine
learning algorithm on a queue where Q is
now as a black box the machine learning
algorithm has no access to that query or
what exactly does the table queue
represent it's just one big Matrix we
already destroyed the the structure of
the data by converting it to one big
Matrix basically
instead what we are aiming for here in
this talk is to operate directly on the
input tables rst which are potentially
much smaller sympatically smaller than Q
in particular we want to develop some
sort of a machine learning algorithm
that can run directly on those input
tables or said otherwise we want to push
the machine learning inside the query
just like in the previous case in the
previous example we pushed the aggregate
inside the query so that's basically
what we are hoping to achieve
now let's take a detour to review some
technical tools that we are going to to
need to develop some class of relational
algorithms and the technical tools that
we are going to need are basically what
we call some product uh
queries
the reason we are going to need them is
that many relational algorithms at least
some class operation algorithms that we
are going to discuss can be described as
a series of solving some product queries
and in general some product queries are
a universal language to express problems
in several domains including databases
linear algebra constraint satisfaction
logic pgms and Etc so it is an important
topic on its own
but for the purpose of the stock we are
going to need it specifically to develop
some relational algorithms
so what exactly do we mean by some
product query
for to specify some product query the
first thing that we need to specify is
basically a commutative summary
which consists basically of a domain
some binary operator that represents
addition a binary operator that
represents multiplication and additive
identity zero a multiplicative identity
and we also need some properties we need
the annulation by zero property and most
importantly
the most distinctive property of
semi-rings is basically the distributive
property where multiplication
distributes over addition in uh
so assuming that we have fixed Assam
ring so how do we actually specify a
some product query
a some product query
consists of a variable set X we need to
fix some set of variables and we also
need to specify subsets of x m subsets
of X so each one of these X1 to XM is a
subset of x
and each one of those subsets let's take
X1 has an Associated function PSI 1 X1
which is a function from the domain of
those variables X1 into D where D is the
domain of the semi-ring
in addition we are we also need another
subset y of X subset of variables and
our Target is basically to compute a
function from the variables y to D the
domain of the semi-ring
and this function is specifically
defined as follows we basically take the
product of these functions PSI 1 up to
psi M and then we take a summation over
all variables X that are not in y in the
output and when we take this summation
we are left with a function over the
variables y a function from the domain
of those variables into d
now this might sound a bit too abstract
but I promise this is actually the only
abstract slide that I have from this
point on everything will just be
examples
so let me
demystify this a bit by taking an
example
this example some productive query over
here we have basically four variables
ABCD and we have three functions PSI one
PSI 2 PSI 3
we are multiplying them together and
summing over BC and the output is a
function over a d
now what exactly does this some product
query represent it depends on what semi
ring do we want to choose and what
functions PSI 1 psi to psi 3 we want to
choose so for example we can use this
sum product query to encode the problem
of uh of detecting from Forever
detecting in a graph e
which pair of vertices A and D have a
three path that goes from a to d
in order to encode the this problem uh
using this spq
the functions of PSI 1 a b becomes the
edge relation a b which basically
returns true if the vertices A and B
have an edge and false otherwise
the product of the semi-ring becomes the
and
and the summation becomes basically the
or or that exists
and now this equally returns whether A
and D have a three path from a to d and
what we used over here is basically the
Boolean semi ring
automatically we could have used the
exact same some product query to count
the number of paths from a to d and for
that purpose we need to use the a
different summary we need to use the
summary of natural numbers we are now
for the function of PSI one a b we need
to use an indicator function
uh indicator function of EAB which
basically returns one if there is an
edge from A to B and 0 otherwise and now
the product of the semi-ring becomes the
numeric multiplication
the summation of the semi-ring becomes
the numer explanation and now q2ad is a
function that Returns the number of
three parts from a to d
alternatively we could also use the same
semi the same spq to ask what is the
shortest path between every pair of
vertices A and D and for that purpose
the functions of PSI 1 becomes the
weight
uh the length of the edge a b and
instead of the product of the semi-ring
we use plus and instead of the summation
we use mean
and now we are Computing short response
alternatively we could also use the same
sbq to encode matrix multiplication
we are now we use Epsilon Cyclops I3 to
encode matrices
we multiply them and sum over BC and the
result is basically a matrix that
represents the product of these matrices
so the beauty of the sum product uh
obstruction is that no matter what is
the domain that we're talking about
whether it's the graphs or matrix
multiplication
we can always solve these queries in the
exact same way using the semi-ring
abstraction using nothing other than the
summary properties
this is just an entry so e so M1 a b
here A B are the two indices of the
Matrix i j and M1 is the value
yeah this would have been probably
easier to see if we replace ABCD with i
j a k
and the same ring is the natural number
so yes
or real numbers
foreign
a slightly more interesting example
suppose that we are given now uh this
query this join the query where RS and
TR relations it's basically a four a
three path query
and let's say our Target is to compute
the minimum L1 Norm among all tuples X1
X2 X3 X4 and when I say one Norm we're
basically talking about the summation of
the absolute values of X1 X2 X3 X4 so we
want to go through all these tools sum
their absolute values and then pick the
value with the minimum value among all
tuples in a queue
so how can we encode the
such a computation as some productive
query
naturally since we're talking about an
L1 Norm which is a summation and a
minimum we should probably be using the
mean plus semi-ring so we have to Define
some functions PSI are X1 X2 plus PSI x
x 2 x 3 plus PSI T and we need to take
the minimum but now the question is how
do we actually Define these functions
PSI R PSI s PSI T to achieve what we
want there are actually several options
one of them is this we can Define if PSI
R to be the summation of the absolute
values of X1 and X2 if X1 and X2 is in R
and infinity otherwise
why did we choose Infinity because it is
the identity of the mean operator which
is the addition of the semi ring so here
we shouldn't really be using 0 we should
be using Infinity
now we can Define sine s a bit
asymmetrically where we only take the
absolute value of x3 if X2 X3 is in s
and the PSI 2 similarly and now let's
see what happens
for any trouble x 1 x 2 x 3 if it does
not satisfy this conjunction
then basically it means it does not
satisfy at least one of those atoms
which basically means that one of these
terms will be Infinity
which means their sum will be Infinity
as well which means it is not really it
is not really going to interact with the
mean
however for a triple X1 X2 X3 X4 that
satisfies this conjunction we are
basically going to get the absolute
value of X1 plus X2 plus x x 3 plus X4
and we are minimizing over all X1 X2 X3
X4
so as a some product query this does
indeed compute uh what we specified over
here
so obviously you could have made the
different choices sorry
yes uh associated with them in a
different way yes
what kind of framework would allow one
to prove that those who grades
these two different choices but actually
it would work
like given a specific choice we can
actually improve that it is equivalent
by basically considering tools X1 X2
basically combinations of variables that
satisfy this conjunction and take the
product of all the values that we have
but it is in some cases it is actually
interesting to try to see like the
Symmetry between these options because
it's not it's not necessarily the case
that you will get the same performance
if you use any of those uh options in
fact this is also an issue that we have
in implementation
so there's an optimization that you are
opposed Justified
but then you want to apply it creatively
yeah yeah like in our implementation
addressing for some productive queries
we do have a heuristic to try to
construct these functions where we want
to establish a mapping like this that
can be as helpful as uh as possible to
us
okay so now that we have agreed what
spqs look like so now we are going to
start discussing how to actually solve
the spqs
and apologies here to the database
Community who are already bored with the
triangle query because unfortunately I'm
going to use the Triangular query but
then remember that not all our audience
comes from database community and our
Target here is to join our boredom with
the algorithms Community as well
and optimizing yeah
okay so let's take this uh spq over some
summary that we don't even need to
specify that's the beauty of uh the spq
obstruction
so over here we have three variables and
the three functions and we are summing
away over y z to compute the function
over X
so how can we compute this using a join
algorithm it turns out we can actually
reduce the problem of solving this query
into resolving a database drawing a
query where we construct the three
relations or s and t take their join
where these relations are specifically
defined as follows
uh R is basically the set of tables X Y
for which PSI 1 X Y is not zero and by
zero here I mean the additive identity
of the semi ring
and how does that exactly work so
for any trouble x y z
that does not satisfy this conjunction
it basically means that it does not
satisfy at least one of these three
atoms which basically means one of these
up size is going to be zero which
basically means this product is going to
be zero so for any trouble x y z that
does not satisfy the conjunction its
contribution to the to this product is
going to be zero and therefore it's
going to its contribution to the
summation will also be zero so it's we
can ignore it so we can only focus on
turbulence X Y and Z that satisfy this
join this is basically the idea why we
can reduce this into a join query
and now once we solve this join the
query we can list tuples uh x y z that
satisfy the joint for each one of those
those tools compute this product
and then some away the Y and Z to get
our Target function
and we can do this using either a worst
case optimal join algorithm or some
Beyond whereas case or human uh join
algorithm
if you need more information or
background about versus small joint
algorithms the the hung actually in the
boot camp of this program about a month
ago gave a couple of nice tutorials
and just a quick review for how do we
measure the runtime of overseas optimal
join algorithms because we are going to
need this later
the the runtime of our system algorithm
is described in terms of a fractional
Edge covers
so a fractional Edge cover is basically
a coefficient assignment of coefficients
that are associated with every relation
in the query so the relation R has a
coefficient of PSI are and these two
options are non-negative numbers
uh production Edge cover is valid if
every variable is receiving a total of
coefficients from its adjacent relations
that are at least one so for example
here if we assign a coefficient of every
relation to B1 then this variable will
be receiving at least one this variable
will be receiving at least one
so this is a valid production Edge cover
and to estimate the runtime of worst
case optimal join we need actually the
minimum fractional Edge cover the one
that minimizes this summation the sum of
the coefficients and this is what we
call row star or the fractional Edge
cover number
and assuming that we have this number
for a given query
the AGM bound basically says that the
output size of the query is upper
bounded by n to raw star where n is the
size of these relations in the sparse
representation
[Music]
log Factor
now how does this raw star look like for
a cake lick it actually looks pretty
good because raw star is just K over 2
for a k click but for a k-path it's
actually a pretty bad it's also K over
two but the k-path is actually much
easier than uh Okay click
so which basically means where the
terminal joins might not be enough to
solve the spqs efficiently which leads
us to our next idea
so now let's take this uh three path
spq where we have four variables x y z t
and the three functions and we are
multiplying them and summing away x y z
t
so how can we solve this more
efficiently than simply taking uh like
raw star the fractional Edge cover with
which in this case would have will cost
us an N squared time because we need at
least two of these relations to cover
the variables
now we can notice the following
summation over t
but these two functions do not really
involve t
so basically using the semi-ring
distributive property we can pull these
two functions outside the summation over
T so that's the summation over T only
erupts this function
specifically we can do this as follows
so we push the summation over T inside
so that it's only over upside three
using the distributive property of the
semi ring and what we have over here
this expression now
is just a function over Z that we can
compute up front and it can be computed
in linear time in the size of PSI 3 or
more specifically the size of the sparse
representation of PSI 3 or the number of
non-zero entries in PSI 3.
now once we compute this we kind of plug
it in back into Phi
and now we have a query that no longer
has a variability it only has variables
x y z
this is basically what we mean by
variable elimination so we started from
a query that that is over xyzt and using
this step we created the query that is
just over XYZ we eliminated a variable t
we can do this one more time let's say
over variable Z so we can notice that
PSI 1 does not really involve Z
and this enables us to push the
summation over Z inside and now we can
compute a function over only Y in time
which is linear in the size of the
sparse representation of upside two and
now we are left with this equity which
does not involve even Z so we eliminate
two variables and we are left with only
x y
who follow this strategy you can
basically solve this spq over any semi
ring in linear time basically in the
sizes Hoops I want PSI tube PSI 3.
so now the question is
how far uh does this strategy generalize
so here is a more uh interesting query
to test this idea and so in this
security I'm taking basically we have
overall five variables a b c d e and we
also have five functions I'm thinking
here of rst not as database relations
but as functions to the domain of the
semi ring we are summing away BCD and E
to get a function over a
another question is which variable
should we choose to eliminate and what
exactly is that going to cost us based
on the variable that we choose to
eliminate so let's say we choose to
eliminate d
if we choose to eliminate d d is
involved in two of these functions uh uh
W and T
so if we try to eliminate D we will
basically pull everything else outside
of the summation over D so that inside
we only have t and w
but still this elimination this
elimination is going to compute this
factor of PSI d uh which is over BCE it
no longer has D because we are summing D
away but still this is actually going to
cost us uh quadratic time
but we might be able to do better so
let's try another variable
what happens if we try to eliminate e
if we try to eliminate e there are only
two factors two two input functions that
basically involve e u and W so using the
same logic we basically get uh
to eliminate e we will basically have to
compute this expression which computes a
function of PSI e
but even this is still quadratic it
takes time N squared
however we can eliminate in a little bit
uh smarter in particular in this
expression
we can also include an extra Factor T
Prime CD and this function T Prime CD is
just a zero one function that returns uh
one whenever tbcd has at least one B
value for which tbcd is non-zero
and you can argue that adding this
function T Prime in here is not really
going to change the function Phi because
T Prime is always zero one and it can
only be Zero by definition if T itself
is zero therefore plugging in t Prime in
here does not really change Phi and this
is basically what enables us to pull off
this trick and now when we eliminate e
we have a triangle
instead of just including those two
relations now we have this T brown which
is a spanning CD and this is basically a
triangle that we can now solve using uh
where sketch optimal join algorithm to
get uh n to the power of 1.5
so this is basically the strategy that
we are going to use to solve spqs we are
going to look for a variable to
eliminate when we eliminate it we have
to solve a smaller spq in this case this
is the smaller sbq that you have to
solve for it to Element e with sbq we
call it PSI e something
and to solve this spq we are going to
use a wireless case document join
algorithm but we are also going to try
to utilize as many projections as we can
to drive down the fractional Edge cover
number that we are using to measure the
runtime of the wireless case of human
joint algorithm
and now the question is how do we
measure the runtime for a strategy like
this to solve some product queries
yes do you have some way to figure out
which order would be better for
eliminating the valuables
how do you know do you have some method
by which you know that you should
eliminate if else because the yes yeah
so this is basically what uh what I'm
going to Define here so over here we are
going to Define an ocean which is the
some productive query which which
basically a measure of the runtime for
uh the best possible runtime over all
variable elimination orders and we have
a result that basically reduces uh
approximating the sum product equally
width to approximating the fractional
laboratory width
that we can use as a black box so that
we can approximate the some product
equally width
so if
the the fractional tree was yes
with respect to the fractional cover of
like just kind of like like the basic LP
for the problem is the fractional cover
it's the partition however three with
which is a bit more complicated than the
fractional Edge cover and yeah
unfortunately Computing the fraction
number three bit itself is actually
pretty difficult because it's not just a
matter of linear program because we need
to break down the query into three all
possible 3D compositions but there is
actually a polynomial time approximation
algorithm for the fraction laboratory
width that we we here rely on to
approximate also this notion of weight
yeah
so if we fix a variable order Sigma
then in order to measure the runtime for
this elimination process we have to go
through every variable in Sigma and
eliminate them one by one
in order to eliminate them as we
discussed in the previous slide we have
to solve some smaller spq that
eliminates V
so I'm call it here upside V and it also
depends on the elimination order
in order to solve this Equity we have to
pay a cost which is the fractional Edge
cover number row star for this
particular spq so this expression over
here measures the overall cost that we
have to pay if we pick Sigma
as a variable elimination order if we
minimize overall Sigma
this is basically what we Define as the
some product query width
protection help me understand this the
expression inside the parenthesis
if you go to your previous life you
change the query by adding the atom the
prime yes
how do you
what what are you allowed to enter how
do you feel your resulting elimination
cost
foreign
Yeah so basically uh the way we describe
it is as follows so in order to
eliminate uh let's say a variable e
we have to Define uh a new function we
have to solve an spq over CED
because because e is involved directly
with c and d are neighbors in of e in
this hybrid graph now the quantity raw
star
uh that I'm using here
is basically the fractional Edge cover
number of this subset of the hyper graph
C D and E
and um
correctly you're going to include not
just a projection of t on E but also as
a projection on S which didn't help you
but you include everything that contains
variables from your stronger Factor yes
that's basically the definition of the
production Edge cover number uh of a
subset of variables in a hybrid graph we
are basically allowed to use hybrid
edges that are not directly included in
the subset that we are interested in and
there is an algorithmic justification
for this in the sense that we can indeed
algorithmically utilize them so we allow
them and this is indeed how the fraction
number three width is defined so for
this query it is indeed true that the
fractional hybrid tree with like as
defined in textbook it should be 1.5 it
shouldn't be N squared or it should be
two
foreign
of the runtime in particular end to the
some other query width measures the
runtime within an extra log factor and
some factors that depend on the query
size here I'm just focusing on the data
complexity so and to some other to some
some product query width is a measure of
the runtime of this variable elimination
strategy that I just described
so here are some special cases to think
about this expression this expression
some product query width is one for uh
Alpha acyclic queries without free
variables
and it's also one for free context
queries which no far told us about uh
yesterday
for queries without three variables in
general it reduces back to the
fractional laboratory width
and for more background about 3D
compositions and with measure I also
invite you to
[Music]
tutorial in The Bootcamp about a month
ago
for queries with the three variables it
is not it could be higher than the
fractional hypertrived
and we will see a couple of examples
is the variable elimination here how
does it relate to semi-joints and Yana
carcass and stuff like that it feels
like a generalization
so yanakages can be seen uh as a special
case when we apply this variable
elimination strategy on acyclic queries
over the Boolean Sami ring
yeah yeah so this is the generalization
of that yes
basically
okay
uh yeah
see variables it's not clear it's still
open
yeah so three variables tend to increase
that you can no longer talk about the
fraction however you can like the some
productivity could be higher than the
fractions for the same reason that
queries uh even if they are acyclic but
they are not free contacts you cannot do
them in linear time in fact I have an
example over here
notion that quantifies the business that
you variables
yeah yeah so the notion of this with
with the three variables is by
definition the sum productive query with
so the fraction operator with the does
not really take a free variables in into
consideration because it's just defined
over a hyper graph it is not defined
over a query
the reason why you respect to one
elimination
of this is a modular weight
roughly the same but you can also split
your tablets and then use different
elimination orders and different parts
that's indeed true so for the various of
the stock we just wanted to stick to
like the basic thing that we need in
order to get out of idea regarding
decimating some relative queries so yeah
it is not really the state of the art uh
the someone they always can actually
drive
Valentine even further
rings
that is indeed true yeah so for in
general for uh the sum of your weight
only works for the Boolean summary for
other semi Rings we have a notion of
sharp some of these are weights
yes it does work for others I mean in
general not just for counting yeah
yeah so this story is is not really
meant to be like to be full background
on which measures it's just meant to
give like a minimal subset that is
needed for us to discuss our next
relational algorithm
the relationship between this spq width
and the reflection hypotuitive is it the
same as between acyclic and free conics
so that you just add an artificial hyper
edge with the free variables and then
you determine a fraction hyper
3D composition yes you can think of it
this way like the gap between those two
in general when we have three bars it's
just to account for the free connect
City effect okay
so
so let's say for example this uh three
path query xyzw where we are summing
away everything so what do you think the
spq width should be
this time
yeah it is actually one
now suppose that we change it a little
bit so that we are grouping y y z
foreign
X
which basically means it's a state one
but now here's a more interesting case
so so now let's take a two-path query x
y y z but we are summing away y
so this is not really free convex
and here we have to pay a price of two
in particular here we run in time N
squared
like in the sparsity of R and S this is
basically sparse matrix multiplication
by the way there are actually better
results so as I mentioned before uh spq
it is not really the set of the art so
it's for this sparse matrix
multiplication it's possible to do it in
using a combinatorial uh algorithm in a
better runtime which is more output
sensitive but this is probably beyond
the the scope of this talk if you want
if anyone is interested I can tell you
like afterwards in private
excuse me but but shouldn't it be 1.5 I
mean you you're throwing this artificial
hyper Edge which consists of the output
variables then you have a triangle and
then it should be 1.5 so this is exactly
what I was just talking about it's not
exactly n to the power of 1.5 it is n
times uh square square root of the
output size the square root of the
sparsity of Q3
this is exactly what I
basically was referring to so yeah it is
indeed possible to utilize the triangle
occurring even though this is not a
triangle it is possible to utilize the
time analysis for the Triangular query
to get uh
uh runtime of n times square root of the
output size or the sparsity of the
output so it's basically the sparsity of
the input times the square of the
sparsity of the output
so this tool is basically uh sort of
like an outer product
yes yes
because in the worst case we could have
only one y value and we have an outer
product uh
of x and z here
now what happens if we have a product of
three matrices rst
any guesses on the spq width
yeah it should be two it doesn't really
increase because we basically do these
eliminations one at a time we eliminate
Z basically multiplying rst
so it doesn't really increase the weight
so with that uh we have all the
background the that we need on spqs
so that we can we are now ready to get
into
uh our example our example of our
relation algorithm which is going to be
a linear regression applied relationally
so let me give you a few references so
what I'm going to describe right now the
message I'm going to describe is based
actually on this paper which is
originally pots 18 paper then ultiana's
group at Zurich previously at Oxford has
a series of systems papers pushing the
boundaries
of relational algorithms to cover more
and more machine learning models
in fact then the student Max Schleich
who is currently at relational I did his
entire PhD on this topic and also our
own Commerce group at UC San Diego has a
parallel research thread
on this topic and we actually have been
involved with many of these papers
spearheaded by Hong so basically I have
two points to make here on this slide
first I want to give you some references
but also I wanted to point out that
there are like many experts working in
this area and I'm actually very far from
being the best expert to give this talk
but I happen to be the cheapest one
around so this is why I'm talking to you
today yeah
Welcome to our budget program
okay so how does relational linear
regression look like what is exactly is
the setup
in the relational setup for linear
regression our training data is not
given accessibility instead it's given
to us as a join a query
in particular here we are given these
three tables where the first table
Maps a pair of items and a city to the
sales of this item in the city
we have another table that lists item uh
let's lists pairs of item and price I'm
not assuming here that there is a
functional dependency from item to price
because the same item could have
multiple prices on multiple days or
multiple places
and we also have another table that Maps
a city to its country
and our training data is basically the
join of those uh
comes from the join of those tables into
one big uh table queue which has uh five
columns so this Equity is what we call
the feature extraction query in the
sense that it basically extracts the
features that we want to use for
training
Target
additional linear regression so in this
example let's say is to learn how to
predict sales based on these four
features
you said variable elimination
generalizes but for exciting full
conductive queries runs in linear time
we had variable elimination could be the
same as uh worst case Optical joints
since there is nothing to eliminate
yeah that's also I was thinking of yakis
without three variables
yeah
so what we want here is basically to
predict sales based on item price City
and Country and we are going to use
basically linear regression with square
loss which I'm going to review shortly
so in a traditional machine learning
setup which what we call structural
structure agnostic or non-relational
the first step that we do is basically
to compute the join queue to materialize
this big table which is potentially much
larger than the input tables themselves
and not only that in a traditional
machine learning setup we also have to
one hot encoded so remember that item
City and country are categorical
features whose numerical values don't
really have any inherence meaning so it
doesn't really
make any sense to use like some numeric
value for code in our learning model
instead we have to go one hot encode a
vector of items so that let's say a code
is encoded as one zero shows will be
equaled as 0 1 and we have to do this
for uh also cities and countries so we
get this table one hot coded table which
is much potentially much larger
and
our model for relational regression
basically means we want to find a vector
Theta
whose dimensionality is the same as
these features
such that the inner product
of this Vector with every row of this
table is as close as possible to our
Target
sales
let me give you a more precise
definition
so here in our training data these in
every Row in the training data this is
basically the vector X of features and
this is our Target y
and basically our Target is to find the
Theta that minimizes the following
expression over here we have Theta times
x this inner product is our prediction
for a given a combination of input
features X using our parameter Vector
Theta and our Target that we are trying
to aim for to get the best Theta that uh
as close as possible to it is basically
y so we are trying to minimize the
so we basically take the error which is
basically the difference between uh our
prediction
versus the true Y and we Square the
difference and we sum overall
pairs in our training data
so this term over here captures the
least squares loss
the error in like our prediction versus
the True Values that we are trying to
predict and over here we will have
another term that is basically going to
penalize the large thetas
so so that it basically can reduce
uh overfitting so this is what
achieved objective function for linear
regression with the least squares and an
L2 regularizer uh look like
and uh like for the purpose of this talk
we will think of batch gradient descent
that is being used to compute the
optimal Theta where we iteratively uh
improve our Theta by applying this over
and over
so what exactly is wrong with the
traditional machine learning that is
basically structure agnostic in a
relational setup there are actually
several issues one of them is that we
have a twofold size blow up
in our training data in particular we
start from these input tables SP and C
we compute their join which is
potentially asymptotically larger and we
have to one hot encoded which is even
potentially much larger than queue
itself so we have a two-fold size blow
up
and we are also destroying the data
structure because once we compute The
Matrix data and feed it to the machine
learning algorithm the machine learning
algorithm has no access to what these
features represent or wherever where
they came from we will lose access
basically the machine learning algorithm
will lose access to the joint
dependencies and function dependencies
in the data and it will help to do some
extra work to ReDiscover those
dependencies
moreover there will be some expensive
data move between the database into the
machine learning we'll have to export
our data and then train the model in the
machine learning and then import the
model back into the database
and there are also other issues for
example related to high maintenance cost
now suppose that after we train our
model there is some insertion let's say
into the table s and our Target is to
figure out how this affects our learns
model it's really hard in
set up to compute how this uh affects
our trained model without recomputing
everything from scratch
so instead
in relational machine learning our
Target is basically to address some of
those concerns
here is the outline of one potential
approach that I'm going to describe here
in detail how we applied for this
particular example
the first step is going to be we will
factor out
computations that are independent from
Theta
now remember that Theta is going to
change when we apply batch gradient
descent so computations that are
independent from Theta we can compute
them only once at the beginning and when
we apply battery in this and they don't
really have to be updated anymore
Step 2 is going to be encoding these
computations as some product queries
which is why I wasted half an hour
recalling some product queries and there
are there are actually two benefits to
encoding them to some product queries we
already have efficient algorithms to
solve some other queries that will
Factor the computation over uh the input
table so that we don't have to do the
join and I'm going to give you some
exactly how this how this works out in
this example
even better
when we have when we have like a bunch
of sbqs as we will see shortly many of
these sbqs I was going to share some
computation so we don't really have to
solve them independently we can reuse
some components of these spqs to help
one another
reducing the overall uh cost
so let's substantiate now each one of
these steps one at a time so what
exactly do we mean by factoring out uh
the Theta independent computations
this is basically our objective function
in terms of theta
our Target is to basically to pull Theta
out as much as possible or set otherwise
we want to push this summation over our
training data inside as much as possible
if we expand this square and push the
summation inside you will basically get
these three summations over here we have
basically a matrix that is sandwiched
between two thetas and this Matrix
turns out to be what we call the The
covariance Matrix of the data in
particular it's a summation over every
feature Vector X and Target y e of our
training data a summation of the outer
product of X with itself
so this is a square Matrix whose
dimensionality is basically number of
features times number of features in one
hundred encoding we have over here like
a similar Vector which is basically a
summation
uh of x times y for every input feature
X and its corresponding in Target Y and
over here there is another scalar
which is a summation of Y squared so
basically these three quantities Sigma C
and S we can compute them only once and
we don't really have to touch them
anymore during gradient descent
and they depend on the data they are the
only thing that depends on the data
Theta itself does not really depend on
the data so this is basically what we
are hoping to achieve and the same
actually applies for the gradient when
we compute the gradient the gradient is
directly written in terms of Sigma and C
so we are going to start by Computing
this term Sigma C and S separately and
then let's just focus on Sigma
recover that this is basically what our
training data looks like so these
columns without sales these are X our
input feature the vector X in the
previous slide and this is why our
Target
now imagine a square Matrix which has
the same number of rows and columns
where we basically go through every Row
in this Matrix and take its outer
product with itself
now the Matrix Sigma that I described in
the previous slide is basically this
portion
of the Matrix where we go over only this
part and take its uh its outer product
with itself and some overall rows in the
training data this uh this Matrix is
also symmetric so the vector C that I
described in the previous slide can be
seen either as this portion or as this
portion
and the scalar s is right here in the
corner
and if we look more closely so now let's
focus on Sigma itself how are we going
to compute yes
yes hopefully it could be enough time
yeah
so the Matrix Sigma
can be broken down into smaller
parts
over here I'm calling them
like so for item I'm going to we are
going to have a block inside Sigma which
is Sigma item item now Sigma item item
is one part of the big Matrix Sigma one
block and it results by going through
each row here and looking only at the
one hot coded Vector item and taking its
outer product with itself
and something over all rows when we do
this notice that Sigma item item is a
diagonal matrix
and similarly over here so so over here
we will have another block of Sigma
called the sigma item city which results
by going through these rows one by one
and taking the outer product of item
with the city
and as a result we're going to get uh
zero one Matrix not a zero one metrics
when we do a summation it will no longer
be zero one but it will have it will be
a two by three Matrix so we will have to
compute all of these
sub matrices or blocks in order to
compute Sigma overall so how are we
going to encode these as
some product queries
remember that this is basically our
query our joining query that computes uh
Q Sigma item item
Matrix it is enough for us to compute
only the diagonal entries we don't have
to compute the full Matrix
if you follow through the definition
from the previous slide Sigma item item
basically results from going through all
tuples items City Country sales in a
queue
and grouping them by item and Counting
how many triples we have per item
so basically in order to compute this
entry
we have to go over every item and count
how many triples uh Price City Country
sales are in matching this particular
item we can express this as the
following spq
where over here we are using indicator
functions One S uh item City sales so
this indicator function returns one if
the triple item City sales in is in s
and 0 otherwise and we over here we have
another indicator 1p 1C
uh we take their product so their
product is going to be one
only when the triple item right City
Country sales is in a queue
and we are doing a summation of our
bright City Country sales so when we
take this summation we will basically
count for every item the total number of
doubles in a queue
for this particular item so this is the
spq for item icon there is a similar spq
for item City
it's exactly the same thing so over here
we didn't really change this conjunction
it is a product however over here now we
are grouping by item City so for every
pair item City now our Target is to
count entries uh in a queue with the
spare item City
now what happens if we consider let's
say a continuous variable price and
let's say we want to look at a sigma
item price
for Sigma item price
is a continuous variable so our Target
basically is to for every item
to compute the summation of a price for
All tuples In A queue that have this
item
so for every item we sum away price over
all entries in a queue that have this
item and this also can be represented as
an spq like this
and if we have if you are interested
let's say in Sigma price price it's a
similar spq except that we are taking a
price squared and uh summing away over
all variables so then the thing to
remember here is that for every entry of
Sigma there is an spq there's a this is
these spqs look very similar they only
differ in two aspects they differ in
potentially some uh some some variable
here or some some combination of
variables that we are multiplying into
these indicators over here we have let's
say plus squared over here we have
nothing and they also differ in their
group by variables and which variables
we are summing
even better so now so now once we
construct these spqs we can use what we
learned about solving spqs to solve them
efficiently so if we take let's say this
sbq and applying uh variable elimination
we can basically Factor this out into
smaller sbqs if we eliminate price first
we will discover that we have to compute
this expression independently if we
compute if we eliminate country
afterwards we will discover that we have
to compute this expression separately
and so on so this entire sbq can be
actually solved in linear time
in in each one of the input tables if we
compute each one of those Sub sub
Expressions separately using variable
elimination
if you take another spq there will be
actually a similar uh
variable elimination
strategy where we will but we will also
discover that we we have these sub
Expressions to compute separately so
variable elimination helped us basically
avoid Computing this join
but even better if you look at the
result of variable elimination for those
two different parts of Sigma you can
notice that they share some Expressions
so this expression we only have to
compute it once
for both entries
and similarly for this expression so
basically there are two benefits to
variable elimination avoiding the join
and sharing computation
among the different components of Sigma
yes business
conditional Independence marshallization
and graphical models isn't it isomorphic
to that
yes yes in fact uh spqs like one
possible application is solving pgms by
taking advantage of conditional
Independence okay thanks
so overall what did we gain by applying
machine learning relationally and with
rubber in a couple of minutes I know I'm
running a bit late
so one thing is that database relations
serve as a sparse sparse sensor
representation uh
out of the box
so like in the previous uh case let's
say just because we encode these tables
as spqs in a database where these are
represented in a sparse way the output
naturally is going to be a sparse Matrix
we will never basically let's say
materialize pairs item City for which
there is no combination in the training
data for this spare item City so
everything out of the box when you
implement it in a database will turn out
to be a spar sensor
moreover when we encode these like uh uh
relationally and use a reliable database
engine we can utilize the query
optimization so for example if we have
good support for spq solving in our
database we as we saw we can utilize sbq
moreover database equal optimizers
typically have many other optimizations
they can for example take advantage of
Integrity constraints so for example if
we have a functional dependency from
City to Country
a reasonable database Optimizer would
figure out that this summation where we
are summing away country over every city
is actually trivial because of the
functional dependency we can also
utilize whereas this ultimate joint
algorithms if our database supports
versus joint algorithms we will also get
other benefits so typically databases
support parallelization and just because
we encoded our machine learning
algorithms as a database a series of
database queries we will get a
distributed machine learning algorithm
for free out of this
even better
we can get free support for uh
incremental uh
machine learning where basically just
because our we encoded everything as
database queries if this database
queries are incrementally maintained
then our machine learning model is now
incrementally maintained
after every insertion let's say into the
input tables our database is going to
automatically maintain the spqs and by
extension the metrics Sigma and by
extension the model
yeah so let me wrap up here I'm going to
skip this part by the way the slides are
available uh
online there is a Google drive folder
that's odiba created that contains
basically slides for the entire program
including this Workshop
so how far can we generalize the
this example out of the box we can
generalize it to polynomial regression
factorization machines if we allow for
extra tricks we can generalize it
actually to a lot more models you can
support piecewise linear or polynomial
functions but then we will need to
support sbqs with some linear
inequalities in them Kirk is going to
tell us more about that and we can also
support svm's classification regression
trees and a lot more once we support
expertise
but fundamentally there are models
especially the models that are
completely outside the scope
of this approach
and the the most natural open problem
basically is to see how potentially we
can support the
deep architecture like even neural
network in particular
like based on relational data we can
either think of uh designing a specific
model structure that is tailored for the
relational data structure that we have
as an analogy
for graphs we do have a graph and neural
networks
so for factorized data do we know
whether there is some notion of
factorize the neural networks that are
really tailored
to learn over factorized data Wolfgang
actually told me before the talk that
operative there's already somewhere
in this direction that he has been
working on
and if we don't want to to tailor a
model structure for the relational data
we can at least talk about restricting
the model parameter space to take
advantage of what we know about the
relational data so for example can we
import some reasonable constraints on
the model parameters the weights
while still showing that thanks to the
relational structure we are not only
going to lose anything in the Precision
potentially speeding up gradient descent
I'm really sorry for going over time and
really appreciate your attention
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a copybreaking yeah that would be
right there